Trascrizione:
Mi è stato chiesto
di parlare di scuola del futuro.
Un'impresa ardua, un'impresa complessa,
soprattutto se da realizzarsi
in questi 15 minuti, o giù di lì,
che mi sono, che ci sono concessi.
Allora io ho pensato
che una strategia per cavarmela
potesse essere quella
di portare su questo palco
una serie di brevi riflessioni,
una serie di evidenze circoscritte
utili, mi auguro,
per garantire un futuro alla scuola.
E allora, voi potreste chiedermi:
dovevi parlarci del futuro della scuola,
anzi della scuola del futuro,
e vieni qui per garantire
un futuro alla scuola?
Sembra uno di quei giochi di parole
tipici dei filosofi.
Un mio amico che, non a caso,
ha finito con fare l'ingegnere,
nulla di male, per carità,
diceva che i filosofi sono bravi
solo negli atti astrusi per usi astratti,
come questo potrebbe sembrare,
In realtà,
con questo mio tentativo,
con questo mio sforzo,
vorrei anzitutto condividere con voi
un'antica lezione,
tanto antica quanto preziosa,
che sintetizzerei così:
ciò che non evolve
rischia di estinguersi.
E la scuola non fa
eccezione a questa regola,
chiamiamola in questi termini,
non fa eccezione a questa legge.
Quindi dobbiamo farci i conti,
dobbiamo prenderla sul serio,
come fosse una sfida;
e cosa significa
prendere sul serio questa sfida,
fare i conti con questa lezione,
che per lo meno ci arriva
dalla seconda metà dell'Ottocento?
Significa, tra l'altro,
fare i conti, dentro e fuori la scuola,
anche con le tecnologie,
che a loro volta evolvono
insieme a noi, sono qui.
Sono qui insieme a noi per restare:
fanno parte, lo crediate o no,
della nostra storia.
Non saremmo quello che siamo,
non penseremmo come pensiamo
se non avessimo interagito
in un certo modo
con le tecnologie che hanno scandito,
da tempi immemorabili,
la nostra sopravvivenza su questo pianeta.
Quindi, quello che vi voglio dire
è che garantire un futuro alla scuola,
o provare a pensare
a una scuola del futuro,
significa anche fare i conti
con le tecnologie.
Ma partirei da qui.
Che cos'è questo?
È un orecchio, giustamente,
vedo che lo riconoscete.
Intuitivamente, è facile.
Aggiungo:
è un oggetto artistico, è un'opera d'arte,
qualcuno di voi, soprattutto forse
i milanesi, l'avranno riconosciuto,
vedo la signora che, probabilmente,
frequenta il centro di Milano
e quindi avrà consuetudine
con questo orecchio.
È anche uno strumento
tecnologico, è un citofono.
Se voi transitate in via Serbelloni,
e quando arrivate al numero 10 vi fermate,
vedete un edificio elegante, signorile,
che ha questo citofono.
È stato realizzato
da uno dei più grandi esponenti
dell'Art nouveau italiana,
Adolfo Wildt.
E voi direte, ma che c'entra un citofono,
ancorché esteticamente rilevante,
con la scuola, con il futuro della scuola,
con la sfida delle tecnologie?
Con la mia idea,
la mia, se volete, bonaria provocazione
è la seguente:
le tecnologie, le tecnologie digitali,
nell'ultimo periodo, negli ultimi mesi,
ormai dovrei dire nell'ultimo
anno e mezzo, sostanzialmente,
cioè il periodo della pandemia,
nella scuola sono state, sostanzialmente,
eccezion fatta per situazioni
e contesti virtuosi
che già avevano iniziato un percorso
di integrazione sensato col digitale;
ma i grandi numeri, diciamo,
nella scuola italiana
hanno utilizzato il digitale
come un citofono:
per parlarsi, per comunicare.
Per gestire la distanza!
Durante la pandemia
abbiamo dovuto vivere a distanza,
abbiamo dovuto rispettare
la distanza fisica -
attenzione, non sociale, fisica -
anche se si è sempre parlato
di distanziamento sociale.
Abbiamo dovuto rispettare
la distanza fisica
per tentare al meglio
di tutelare la nostra salute.
E dunque, nella scuola,
il digitale è stato utilizzato
come connessione: fine.
C'era una necessità,
un'urgenza, un'emergenza,
quella di garantire
la continuità didattica,
E ci mancherebbe:
era un'emergenza clamorosa, inedita,
mai affrontata prima.
E dunque, il digitale
come un citofono ha funzionato,
in alcuni casi meglio,
in alcuni casi peggio,
per gestire la distanza.
Domanda:
è tutto qui il digitale?
È tutto questo ciò che il digitale
può fare dentro una scuola?
È questo il modo di affrontare,
di gestire la sfida
che questa tecnologia ci pone?
Ci piaccia o non ci piaccia,
non c'è bisogno di essere
né scettici né entusiastici.
A prescindere da apocalittici
e da integrati,
come diceva il maestro Umberto Eco.
Ma è tutto qui?
Esaurita la pandemia,
torneremo all'auspicata -
e chi non l'auspica - presenza
e potremo dimenticarci del digitale?
O semplicemente gestirlo,
appunto, come un citofono,
quando servirà
per gestire quella distanza,
quando magari gli insegnanti e i docenti
non saranno più nello stesso spazio-tempo
dell'insegnamento garantito dall'aula,
quella fisica, quella tradizionale
quella che più o meno tutti,
a prescindere dalle età
di chi è presente in quest'aula
ha frequentato dalle elementari
alle medie, alle superiori,
per non dire all'università.
Forse cambiavano un po'
le dimensioni dell'aula
ma se ci pensate,
la struttura è sempre quella.
Il citofono è una tecnologia
che meriterebbe molta attenzione.
La sua storia è più avventurosa
di quanto uno potrebbe pensare.
È una tecnologia
sostanzialmente dell'Ottocento,
che ha una storia parallela
a quella del telefono.
Ci sono state delle anticipazioni:
siamo a Milano,
Leonardo aveva già immaginato
qualcosa che somigliasse a un citofono:
dei tubi di rame che potevano consentire
di parlare da una torre all'altra.
Anche qui il problema
di gestire la distanza, anche se -
come dire, a riconoscimento
dei meriti di Leonardo,
c'è un passaggio del Codice Atlantico
dove immaginava già una rete,
una rete di tubi
che avrebbe consentito di parlarsi
tra popolazioni diverse:
addirittura diceva di toccarsi,
pensate, era già oltre il web
come noi lo conosciamo,
perlomeno nello sforzo
immaginativo, e non è poco.
Però io, avendo convocato
alcuni illustrissimi -
se mi passate l'approssimazione
per eccesso, colleghi,
tra cui lui,
praticamente dimenticato
nelle scuole e fuori dalle scuole,
Licklider,
uno dei grandi visionari
progettisti della rete
durante la guerra fredda
all'interno dell'ARPA,
io ho portato, appunto, lui per primo
e anche un altro testimone
per provare a decostruire
questo pregiudizio,
questa malacomprensione
della rete, del digitale,
"citofono", se mi passate ormai
questa metafora azzardata,
ma tanto per capirci più rapidamente.
Questo signore - occhio, nel 1968! -
progettando le prime reti,
i primi computer connessi in rete,
scriveva quanto segue.
Vi inviterei, in sala come a casa,
a seguire il testo
facendo attenzione
ad alcune parole chiave,
perché sono parole sulla base delle quali
noi potremmo provare
a immaginare un futuro plausibile
anche per la scuola,
per una scuola che voglia accettare
la sfida col digitale.
"Siamo convinti che stiamo entrando
in un'era tecnologica
in cui saremo in grado di interagire
con la ricchezza
delle informazioni dal vivo,
e non solo nel modo passivo
con cui ci siamo abituati
a utilizzare libri e biblioteche".
Parentesi: non è detto che ci si abitui,
che questo tipo di abitudine
sia l'unica modalità per frequentare
libri e biblioteche,
ma lui stigmatizzava un tipo di abitudine.
E proseguiva:
"Ma come partecipanti attivi
di un processo in corso,
portando un contributo
mediante la nostra interazione,
e non semplicemente ricevendo
qualcosa dalla nostra connessione".
Se questi due passaggi
fossero stati debitamente meditati,
nei mesi della pandemia,
studenti di varia età
e di varia frequentazione scolastica
si sarebbero evitati quell'incollamento
ai video dei loro computer
dall'altra parte dei quali
c' erano insegnanti
che parlavano, parlavano, parlavano,
laddove la continuità della didattica
era garantita da una connessione passiva,
o perlomeno solamente ricettiva.
Ma vi ho detto che
vi ho portato un altro testimone,
facciamo un salto di qualche decennio.
In realtà la testimonianza
è piuttosto recente,
ma sta parlando,
questo testimone, del 1984,
quando lui era un informatico
precario al CERN di Ginevra
e stava progettando quello che
noi ormai diamo per scontato,
cioè il World Wide Web:
sto parlando di Tim Berners-Lee.
Immagine di repertorio,
adesso ha qualche annetto in più:
è vivo e lotta insieme a noi,
ma ha qualche annetto in più.
Ricordando quegli anni, il 1984,
Tim Berners-Lee scriveva quanto segue:
"Sono sempre stato interessato a studiare
la maniera in cui
si collabora tra persone.
Se si stava in un'aula,
si scriveva su una lavagna.
Io cercavo un sistema
che permettesse a tutti di confrontarsi,
e di tenere sotto controllo
la memoria istituzionale di un progetto".
L'ultimo passaggio
richiede un'osservazione:
confrontarsi, al CERN di Ginevra,
cioè all'interno
della comunità scientifica,
allargando il discorso,
non significa che ciascuno
dice la propria opinione
e vabbè, ci si sopporta,
Come funziona tra amici,
in un salotto, con la vecchia zia,
ognuno dice la sua, ci si sopp- no.
Nella comunità scientifica confrontarsi,
quel confrontarsi lì
a cui lui fa riferimento,
significa avere il coraggio
e il dovere morale
di esporre le proprie ipotesi,
le proprie teorie e il proprio pensiero
al rischio e al pericolo di un'obiezione
che viene dall'altra parte
della comunità scientifica
che ti sta ascoltando.
È un dovere per uno scienziato,
per un ricercatore:
qui parliamo di fisici,
ma allarghiamo il discorso.
Un ricercatore ha il dovere di pubblicare.
Per far carriera, certo, ma non solo.
Deve pubblicare per condividere -
fate caso alle parole -
condividere all'interno
di una comunità di pari
quello che lui pensa di aver trovato
di innovativo, originale,
affinché gli altri possano dire la loro,
confermando, correggendo, confutando,
a seconda dei casi, e non è facile.
Bisogna educarsi
a questo tipo di confronto.
In una fruizione passiva dei contenuti,
per tornare alle parole
di Licklider di prima,
non c'è educazione
a questo tipo di confronto.
Ed è dentro questo tipo di confronto
che ci si educa al pensiero critico,
esponendosi al rischio delle obiezioni
ed essendo capaci di obiettare,
quando è il caso, alle opinioni altrui.
Quando Platone diceva,
"La filosofia si fa in due",
questo voleva dire:
pensare filosoficamente
significa sostenere
la difficoltà della dialettica,
del dialogo, del confronto.
Quindi, la rete nasce per implementare
la possibilità di un confronto,
a prescindere dalle distanze,
e anche per, aspetto non banale,
anzi direi fondamentale,
tenere sotto controllo
la memoria istituzionale di un progetto.
Che tradotto in contesti scolastici,
significa monitorare i processi,
acquisire dati per la documentazione,
raccogliere esperienze che varranno poi
per ripensare a quello
che si potrà fare con altri ragazzi.
Anche qui, se si fosse studiata
un po' di storia delle tecnologie,
se si fosse pensato
con le macchine, in questo senso,
forse perfino la pandemia,
esperienza tragica, drammatica,
dove tutti hanno fatto il meglio,
ovviamente, per gestirla,
sarebbe stata diversa,
e sicuramente la scuola avrebbe pensato
un po' di più al suo futuro -
ma corriamo.
Perché io vi voglio portare
un po' più avanti.
Perché il digitale è questo,
è possibilità di confronto
a prescindere dalle distanze,
il digitale è possibilità
di monitorare i processi,
il digitale è possibilità di immaginare
esperienze di apprendimento
che vadano oltre la lezione
trasmissiva e frontale.
Che nessuno vuole archiviare
in modo definitivo,
ma affiancare ad altre
modalità di apprendimento.
Perché noi apprendiamo
in tanti modi, l'essere umano,
non solo stando ad ascoltare
o a imitare qualcuno.
Allora perché non tentare
di ridisegnare questa scena,
con gli strumenti - il digitale
è un mezzo, non è un fine;
non si tratta di digitalizzare la scuola,
ma si tratta di riprogettare
la scena degli apprendimenti
attraverso uno strumento che consente
di monitorare, di tracciare,
di simulare, di sperimentare.
E non solo di connettere, dannazione.
Non è uno strumento di connessione,
non è nato per quello.
E ve lo hanno raccontato, non io,
ma chi l'ha pensato
e l'ha realizzato in diverse epoche.
E il digitale, oltre a tutto ciò,
è anche uno strumento,
uso una brutta parola, multicodicale.
E cosa vuol dire?
Nel digitale, se qualcosa
è da vedere, la si vede.
Se è da ascoltare, la si può ascoltare.
Se è da leggere, la si legge.
Possiamo allargare
l'esperienza di apprendimento:
non c'è solo da leggere.
E con questo tipo di codici
possiamo interagire,
come diceva Licklider prima;
non semplicemente recepirli e basta,
come le foto su un sussidiario.
Con quelle immagini possiamo lavorarci:
possiamo deformarle, ingrandirle,
possiamo entrare, guardarle
da lontano, confrontarle.
Non solo.
Il digitale traduce tutto in dati,
dati che diventano,
che rimangono a disposizione
di chiunque voglia lavorare con quei dati,
maneggiarli, elaborarli.
Ecco allora che nel magnifico,
consentitemi, mondo del digitale
un'immagine può diventare musica,
una musica può diventare testo.
Tutte esperienze, diciamo così,
di traduzione radicale
che sono esperienze cognitive profonde,
che, se debitamente calate in percorsi
di formazione, di apprendimento,
sono esperienze per indagare la realtà,
debitamente analizzata,
trasformata in dati,
ma anche per superarla
in percorsi di creatività.
Quelle che vedete sono delle foto
che ho gentilmente avuto
il permesso di mostrare,
perché il centro internazionale
Loris Malaguzzi,
presieduto dalla professoressa
Claudia Giudici,
mi ha concesso di mostrarvele.
Sono -  potremmo chiamarle aule,
[ma] non sono più aule.
Perché sono degli spazi,
chiamiamole così, di apprendimento,
dove attorno ai bambini
si è provato a costruire
un'esperienza, diciamolo così,
multicodicale degli apprendimenti.
La tradizione di Reggio,
molti di voi la conosceranno,
viene da un'idea di Loris Malaguzzi,
grande pedagogista reggiano,
che diceva che i bambini
hanno cento linguaggi.
Possono esprimersi
potenzialmente in tanti modi:
e perché devono essere limitati
proprio nel momento
in cui devono formarsi?
E perché noi dovremmo
rinunciare al digitale
per, invece, vincolarli
a un contesto che, in termini tecnici,
potremmo definire come ipomediale,
quello della lezione e del libro.
Nulla contro il libro, ovviamente.
Quello che vedete sono spazi
in cui il digitale,
diversi supporti, si integrano,
ma questa è un'integrazione seria,
non ha nulla a che vedere
con quelle cose tipo didattica a distanza,
didattica integrata.
Qui si sono riprogettati gli spazi
e i tempi di apprendimento
per consentire ai bambini di fare
un'esperienza aumentata della realtà,
un'esperienza aumentata della conoscenza;
anche - non solo, ma anche -
attraverso il digitale,
che si aggiunge, amplificandoli,
ai cento linguaggi
di cui parlava Malaguzzi.
Questa in particolare
è un'aula della scuola d'infanzia
"Diana", di Reggio Emilia.
La scuola riconosciuta, anni fa,
come la scuola migliore del mondo
è a Reggio Emilia, e forse
molti di noi non lo sanno.
Vedete? Questi sono i bambini
che stanno facendo scuola.
Qualcuno non lo direbbe,
eppure stanno facendo un'esperienza
come quella che altri bambini fanno
in maniera più costretta,
più vincolata da altre tecnologie,
perché anche il libro è una tecnologia,
ma in maniera aumentata dal digitale,
che consente di aumentare l'esperienza
della realtà e dell'apprendimento.
Chiudo tornando dove abbiamo cominciato,
a quell'orecchio, quell'oggetto estetico,
quell'oggetto tecnologico.
Rileggendo un po' la storia
di quest'opera d'arte, ho appreso
che l'architetto
che la commissionò a Wildt
lo fece non solo perché era una cosa
eccentrica, originale, interessante,
ma perché voleva rappresentare,
con questo orecchio,
l'idea di un palazzo
che non si chiudesse in sé stesso,
ma che si predisponesse
all'ascolto della città,
dei suoi rumori, delle sue voci,
dei suoi movimenti, delle sue suggestioni.
La città è un'officina:
Milano, poi, ancora di più.
Ecco, io mi immagino una scuola
che non si chiuda in sé stessa
come un tabernacolo di
consuetudini didattiche da celebrare,
ma come un'agenzia culturale
che abbia il coraggio e la forza
di porsi in ascolto di una realtà
che cambia, perché evolve.
Diversamente, il rischio
dell'estinzione è plausibile,
e il futuro, be', vedete voi.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)